Prof: Okay,
today we're going to start
talking about ecological
communities;
and this builds on our prior
discussion of competition,
predation and disease.
So I'm first going to give you
the classic view;
by classic, I mean the view of
community ecology from about
forty years ago.
Then I'm going to talk about
something that has become a very
dominant and influential point
of view more recently,
which is top-down control and
trophic cascades.
Then I'm going to emphasize the
importance of history.
So communities are not some
kind of isolated microcosm,
they develop in the real world
and they have a history,
and that's important.
And they also exist in space.
So next time,
actually, we're going to talk a
bit about geography,
island biogeography and
metapopulations.
This is making kind of a jump
ahead into that.
Dispersal really does make a
big difference to the structure
of communities;
and I'll mention that briefly
in this lecture.
And the take-home message
really is that communities,
which consist of basically all
of the species that you find in
a local habitat,
and how they interact with each
other,
have been shown to be shaped by
all of these things:
competition,
predation, parasites and
pathogens;
so in a real system they all
interact.
And it is one of the aims of
community ecologists,
out of this complexity to pull
a few take-home messages that
they can apply broadly.
So we'll be discussing some of
those today.
So the classical view on
competition-driven species
packing, on the planet,
was developed by Evelyn
Hutchinson.
And the key reference is from
just fifty years ago,
"Homage to Santa
Rosalia."
Santa Rosalia was a saint who
had a church named in her honor
in Sicily,
and Hutchinson visited this
church on vacation,
and in a pool in the church he
observed two aquatic bugs.
And one of them was large and
one of them was small,
but otherwise they looked the
same and they ate the same
things.
And so that led him--it's an
amazing generalization,
isn't it?
You're kind of wandering
through the churchyard and you
see a pool and it's got two
species of aquatic bugs in it--
and immediately Hutchinson's
mind jumps out to the whole
planet,
and wonders why are there so
many different kinds of plants
and animals?
And his answer is because
evolution has packed them
tightly into the available
niches.
And if it has done so,
then there should be a limit to
the similarity of competing
species;
which is what he had seen.
He'd seen these two species
living in this pool,
and they're not the same size,
they're different.
And he's wondering what is the
evolutionary process which has
caused them to have different
sizes?
And he thinks it's competition.
And so he measured them,
and then he went back and did a
literature review and came up
with the claim that the body
size of the smaller one seems to
stabilize at about 75%,
as a length measurement of the
body size of the larger one.
And he goes into this.
This is from the paper.
And you can see here that the
kinds of things he's looking at
are mustelids;
so these are weasels,
and this is a mouse,
and then these are two
nuthatches in Iran,
and then these are Galapagos
finches.
And from that he gets a
measurement when allopatric and
a measurement when sympatric;
and basically the summary of
all of this is that species
differ more when they're living
together than when they're
living apart.
It's as though when they are
living together,
they're being pushed by
something to be different.
Okay?
And that was taken as an
estimate of limiting similarity
under competition.
So that's a classical view.
And you've seen previously some
of the data;
you've read about some of the
data that indicate that
competition is important.
A lot of that is field
manipulation experiments.
So that's one idea:
The world is the way it is
because it's shaped by
competition.
The second idea is this idea of
top-down control.
By top-down,
basically the top is the top of
the food chain,
and down is the bottom of the
food chain.
So this is about predators
eating things in a food chain.
And in particular it can
interact with competition.
So one of the early ideas was
that if a top predator prefers
to eat prey that are
competitively superior,
then predation enables the
competitively inferior species
to survive.
So what would happen is if you
pulled out the predator,
so there was no top level in
the food chain,
and you just had say the
herbivores competing with each
other--
the things that would be eating
algae or plants competing with
each other--
then you would find that the
dominant competitor would
exclude the inferior competitor,
which would go extinct,
and you would have a simpler
community.
So in this sense predation is
maintaining biodiversity in the
community,
and it's making possible for
the inferior competitors to do
well because they're better at
escaping the predator.
So the key papers on this are
Brooks and Dodson;
a 1965 paper that was done
here, by two people in this
department.
Stan Dodson was a sophomore
when he helped John Brooks do
this paper.
And they did it on data on
daphnia and other zooplankton,
living in reservoirs and lakes
in Connecticut,
in which there were alewives;
fish that came in,
or were landlocked,
that would be eating some of
the--you'll see the picture in a
minute--that were eating the
zooplankton.
And the other classical paper
is from Bob Payne.
That came out thirty-three
years ago.
And what Bob did was work,
like Joe Connell,
in the rocky intertidal.
Bob worked off the--he worked
on Tatoosh Island,
on the northwest coast of the
United States;
it's on the Olympic Peninsula.
And there he could remove
starfish from the intertidal,
and he did so sort of in blocks
in the intertidal.
And he could go out frequently
enough so that he could really
keep the starfish off,
and then he looked at how the
community reorganized itself
when he removed this top
predator.
Now energy is flowing up
through trophic levels in the
food chain.
And when we talk about top-down
control,
basically we are talking about
how the secondary carnivores,
or the primary carnivores--well
the secondary carnivores are
eating the herbivores,
and the herbivores are
eating--excuse me,
the primary carnivores are
eating the herbivores;
the herbivores are eating the
plants that are trapping solar
energy.
And when we talk about top-down
control,
we're basically talking about
either the secondary or the
primary carnivores,
usually controlling what's
going on below them in the food
chain,
going up this way,
and the omnivores and the
detritivores are usually off in
another loop.
So the food chain idea,
that you go up through a simple
linear chain,
is actually quite a
simplification.
If you look at a food web,
then things get a little bit
more complicated.
This is a food web that you
might find on the north slope of
Alaska,
and it contains birds,
marine animals,
foxes, things living in the
soil, decaying matter.
And you can see that there are
potential flows of matter and
energy in quite a different
number of different directions
in this food web.
So when we simplify that
picture and say there's top-down
control, I just wanted to have
that in the background.
I don't have a food web for
this particular pond here.
This is Lindsley Pond and other
such ponds and lakes in
Connecticut.
But in Lindsley Pond,
what Brooks and Dodson showed
is that if you have an alewife--
I'm going to just go out of
this for a second,
go up here, and go back in--if
you have an alewife in the lake,
and you have an array of
zooplankton,
of different size, okay?
This--that is--there we go.
This is the size distribution
of things in the lake,
when there are no alewives.
You put an alewife into the
lake and you shift the size
distribution down to the smaller
size categories.
So the idea behind this is that
when there are no alewives,
the bigger guys are
out-competing the little guys.
You put the alewife in to eat
the big guys,
and it gives the little guys a
chance.
And basically the ones that are
taken out are Daphnia and this
Mesocyclops;
which is a copepod.
And the ones then which are
allowed to increase in frequency
are little things like
Ceriodaphnia;
that's plankton,
which is a rotifer;
Bosmina, which is another
cladoceran, a relative of
Daphnia;
and Tropocyclops,
which is a small copepod.
So simply by putting this fish
into, or taking it out of a
lake, you completely restructure
the community.
And remember that big things
take longer to mature,
and small things mature more
rapidly.
So what's going on here is not
just a shift in the size
distribution of the species that
live in the lake,
it's a reorganization of the
whole population dynamics and
rate of energy transfer of
things in the lake as well.
And as a Ph.D.
in this department is currently
showing,
it actually alters,
… the presence of the
fish in the lake,
causes an induced response in
the life history of the
zooplankton,
and the induced response,
which is basically that they
shift a lot more energy into
reproduction--
not of growth,
because they're going to get
hammered by the predator--
that causes them to reallocate
their fat reserves in such a way
that the ratio of elements in
their bodies changes.
So these kinds of changes have
very deep-reaching consequences
that cascade through the entire
community and affect not only
energy flow,
but the ratios of elements like
carbon and phosphorus and
nitrogen,
that you find in different
parts of the food chain.
In the rocky intertidal,
the classical story from Bob
Payne has to with Pisaster.
Pisaster is a keystone predator.
By the way, this is an image
taken off of the web,
which is in the public domain.
Pisaster looks like this,
but that's actually not
Pisaster.
Pisaster is a bit oranger.
These are mussels, down here;
and these are the barnacles,
over here;
and these are some predatory
snails.
So what's going on in the rocky
intertidal is that there's a
starfish which is eating snails,
and it is also eating limpets,
like that;
and it's eating mussels,
and it's eating barnacles,
like that.
And if you take out the
starfish, which prefers to eat
mussels, then the mussels
exclude everybody else;
you just get a forest of
mussels that covers the
intertidal.
And you put the starfish back
in, and it will eat up the
mussels and clear space that
allows the others to exist.
So this gives you the general
starting idea of a trophic
cascade.
So those ideas really come from
Brooks and Dodson's observations
on a natural experiment with
alewives,
and Payne's manipulation
experiments with starfish.
And the effects of predation
are seen, under this hypothesis,
as propagating all the way
through food chains or food
webs.
There's a key summary paper
here, if you're interested in
this.
A way to get an anchor in the
literature, and then work
forward and backward,
through Web of Science,
is Pace, Kohl,
Carpenter and Kitchell.
And they define a trophic
cascade as an interaction that
yields an inverse pattern in
abundance or biomass across more
than one link in a food web.
So, as an example,
if you have a simple
three-member food web,
if you have abundant top
predators,
they are reducing the numbers
of the middle level consumers,
and they're increasing the
biomass of the basal producers.
So the enemy of my enemy is
my friend,
is the idea behind a trophic
cascade.
We have an evocative quote
about this.
So this is Aldo Leopold,
one of America's great
conservationists,
who graduated from the Yale
School of Forestry about eighty
years ago.
Student:  A hundred.
Prof: A hundred?
Is this 100-- is it 100 this
year?
I'm getting older,
because I actually visited
Aldo's house in Wisconsin at one
point.
So >.
I'm trying to avoid the
implications of my own age.
So he lived at a time when park
naturalists rode around on
horses,
and he was riding through
parks, in various parts of the
United States,
when he made the observations
on which this quote is based.
So: "Since then I have
lived to see state after state
extirpate its wolves.
I have watched the face of a
many a new wolfless mountain and
seen the south-facing slopes
wrinkle with a maze of new deer
trails.
I have seen every edible bush
and seedling browsed,
first to anemic desuetude and
then to death.
I have seen every edible tree
defoliated to the height of a
saddle horn."
So that's the consequence of
pulling the top predator out of
a North American ecosystem.
And these sorts of trophic
cascades can be observed also
when the logging industry goes
through and clear cuts an area.
If you have well-developed
forest, deer are at fairly low
numbers, and therefore mountain
lions are also at fairly low
numbers.
If you clear-cut the forest,
there's kind of an inverse
trophic cascade.
The deer build up,
because there's a lot of
browse.
The mountain lion population
grows up, but then the trees
grow up.
And as the trees grow up,
the deer go down,
and then there are too many
mountain lions.
So when I was in graduate
school in British Columbia in
Canada,
there was--the forests
surrounding Vancouver were in
this state,
at that time,
and there were a bunch of
hungry mountain lions that were
out looking for food,
and they would come into the
suburbs of Vancouver and do
things like eat dogs.
And one day a man went out and
saw a mountain lion dragging his
son off,
and attacked the mountain lion
with a boat oar that he happened
to have,
and drove it away.
So these kinds of things are
actually still going on.
By the way, the boy survived,
the mountain lion was shot.
And it's a shame that humans
and wildlife have to interact,
at that scale;
it's pretty hard on the
wildlife and it's pretty hard on
the humans.
Okay, here is a summary diagram
of what one means by trophic
cascade.
So you have a carnivore or a
herbivore and a plant.
And this summary diagram
actually introduces a new
element.
This is from one of Os
Schmitz's papers.
Os is a professor in the
Forestry and Environment Science
School.
And what Os is showing is that
besides just changing the
numbers of the population,
at the intermediate level,
the presence of a predator--
the carnivore here--will cause
a herbivore either to reduce its
activity or to shift into a
different habitat.
And he demonstrated this,
by the way,
with field manipulation
experiments in which the top
predator was a spider,
and the herbivore was a
grasshopper,
and the plant was a grass or a
forb.
So if you have a lot of
spiders, they will cause the
grasshoppers to reduce their
activity,
and that will give an indirect
positive effect on the growth
rate of the plants.
And if you have some
grasshoppers that prefer to eat
one kind of grass,
but if the spider is
particularly good at foraging on
that- in that kind of habitat,
and you introduce a spider,
then it will cause the
grasshoppers to switch onto the
less preferred plant,
and this actually causes the
community to reorganize.
So you shouldn't think that the
effect of a trophic cascade is
just on the numbers of the
herbivores, or of whatever is at
the intermediate level.
It changes their behavior,
it changes their habitat
preference,
and, as I indicated earlier,
it changes their life
histories--
in lakes, they have induced
life history responses--
and it changes their ecological
stoichiometry,
it changes the ratios of
elements in the freshwater
system.
So these trophic cascades
really have a lot of effects on
the rate and the nature of
matter and energy flowing
through communities.
Some of them are with great big
photogenic BBC quality kinds of
interactions.
Killer whales like to eat sea
otters, and sea otters like to
eat sea urchins,
and sea urchins like to eat
kelp.
And so one of the classic North
Pacific trophic cascades has to
do with the density of killer
whales and whether or not they
prefer to eat sea otters.
Now, it was observed in the
1980s,
1990s and early twenty-first
century that killer whales were
developing an increasing
preference for eating sea
otters;
which, by the way,
had previously been pretty much
eliminated by the- from the
system by Russian fur traders,
and then had come back in.
And sea otters are something
that people love to observe.
They're extremely cute.
So they have some conservation
cachet.
Do any of you have--given the
context we're operating in,
community ecology,
anybody have an idea on why it
is that killer whales decided to
eat more sea otters?
Was there something that they
might previously have eaten,
that wasn't there anymore?
Student:  Sardines.
Prof: Sardines.
No, killer whales actually have
a hard time handling sardines.
They're a bit small for a
killer whale.
Student:  Salmon.
Prof: Salmon, yes;
Alaska salmon fishery crashed.
Killer whales got hungry and
started eating sea otters.
That's exactly it.
So these kinds of things are
going on all the time,
and predators can switch,
and that's what caused this
particular trophic cascade to
become obvious.
Okay?
The killer whale switched onto
sea otters.
The sea otters declined.
Because the sea otters
declined, the sea urchins went
up, and because the sea urchins
increased, the kelp went down.
So this is from that paper by
Carpenter and Kitchell and
others.
And the take-home message from
this--I certainly do not ever
expect you to memorize something
like that.
It might be nice to go through
and pick out one or two favorite
examples,
or it could be useful as a way
to get an entry to the
literature,
if you wanted to write a paper
on it.
But it's to show you that
trophic cascades have been now
identified in marine,
freshwater and terrestrial
systems.
And there are some very
interesting ones.
For example,
mantids affect insects which
affect plants;
lizards affect grasshoppers
which affect plants;
wolves affect moose which
affect balsam fir;
mosquitoes, mosquito larvae eat
protozoa, which eat bacteria;
etcetera. Okay?
So there are a lot of them.
And it turns out that they play
an important organizing role in
a lot of communities.
Okay so, so far basically we've
seen that the initial view of
how a community is structured--
which is that everything in it
is competing,
and the number species in it
are determined by competition--
was then modified by
experiments and observations
that indicated that predators
have an important influence in
food webs,
and that if predators are
selectively eating superior
competitors,
then they will maintain
biodiversity and they will cause
a trophic cascade,
in the enemy of my enemy is
a friend for the lower
things,
kind of pattern.
Any idea why predators might
prefer the competitively
superior prey?
Student:  There's more
of them.
Prof: There's more of
them,
and so over evolutionary time
they may very well have been
shaped by evolution to be really
good at eating the things that
were most common.
Yes?
Student:  I was going to
say, in certain habits,
they all might be larger than
the successful subspecies.
Prof: That's right.
And so if you are an
economically clever predator,
you might take the biggest
packet of energy available.
Right.
And, of course,
if being a good competitor
actually makes you more
vulnerable,
for some reason--if you are a
tub of lard that can't move very
fast--
then that might do it too.
Okay, now given--that was just
a little summary of where we are
so far.
Now let's see what other kinds
of things will affect community
structure.
Because all of this is very
good in theory,
but when you actually go out
there in the real world and you
look at a real world community,
there are some important things
going on that haven't yet been
put into analysis,
into the analysis,
and one of them is history.
So during the last Ice Age,
patterns were created in North
America that have allowed people
to reconstruct what's going on,
and Margaret Davis did
excellent work reconstructing
the history of the reassembly of
the forests of North America,
after the ice went off.
And Rosie Gillespie has been-
is currently doing a similar
kind of reconstruction of the
assembly of communities in
Hawaii.
And in both cases there are
probes into time.
In the case of the deciduous
forests, the probes are
essentially pollen;
oh, and I'll wrap up with Bob
Ricklef's general perspective.
So what Margaret Davis did was
she went over eastern North
America;
and you can see from the black
dots where she took a lot of her
samples.
Okay?
And these are places where
there was a lake or a bog into
which pollen was falling into
fine layers that could be dated
by year.
And if you have an undisturbed
bog, you are able to go down and
make a core in it and actually
count each year,
as you go back.
So, of course,
this kind of thing can also be
confirmed by carbon 14 dating,
and you can get a number of
crosschecks on the accuracy of
your reconstruction.
What you see is that at the
time of the full glacial extent
of the Wisconsin Ice Sheet,
you'll notice that it probed
down well into southern Indiana
here,
and actually it came--right
under here it is out over Long
Island.
The shoreline had dropped,
as water was withdrawn from the
oceans into the icecap.
We had tundra conditions in
southern New York and in
Pennsylvania,
and you had a spruce pine
forest that went all the way
down into southern Georgia and
north Texas,
and then you had a kind of a
refuge down here for deciduous
trees.
And as you can see from this
sketch over here on the side,
if you wash the sediments out,
pollen has the great
advantage--
if you're a palynologist--of
preserving its shape very well.
Pollen is really tough stuff.
The plants have evolved a lot
of ways of preserving their
precious DNA,
and that serves us well.
So this is--you're not looking
at DNA here, you're looking at
the various kinds of structures
that pollen gets packaged in.
The important thing is they're
really well preserved in pollen,
and you can tell the
difference.
Okay?
So when Margaret reconstructed
these things,
she discovered that the first
things to come back north,
after the ice melted off,
were spruce and larch.
And so this is basically how
long ago it was that spruce got
this far north:
14,000 years ago,
12,000 years ago;
10,000 years ago it was pushing
up into Canada.
Larch moving up at a fairly
similar rate;
up here getting a bit north of
Quebec City, about 8000 years
ago.
So you can reconstruct that
pattern for these conifers,
and then you can also
reconstruct it for hickory and
chestnut.
So hickory gets to Maine about
4000 years ago,
and chestnut only gets there
1500 years ago.
Now, if you were sitting at any
particular spot,
like say Albany,
and you lived for 10,000 years
and you were just checking off
well when did that one arrive,
and when did that one arrive,
you would see them coming in at
different times.
And, by the way,
just as a note on the
importance of disease in
structuring ecosystems,
at one point there was
evidently an outbreak of a
forest disease that pretty much
cleared out an area that ran
from Massachusetts to Minnesota.
That happened about 10 or
12,000 years ago.
So the forests just basically
all died, and then they were
re-established,
and it probably was a disease
or a forest insect outbreak that
did it.
That's also in the record.
So they come,
in at any particular point,
at different times.
Now that's an important comment
on the idea of ecological
succession,
because a modern community,
if you were just to look at it
in time,
and you were to forget history,
it would--
you could take communities from
across a broad range of North
America and they would all have
very similar species
compositions;
they would all have these
different hardwood and conifer
species in them.
And it might be that you would
postulate that--
you'd have a working
hypothesis--that these species
had to be there in a particular
mix in order to co-exist.
The historical record indicates
that's not true at all.
They had quite different
sequences of assembly.
So it wasn't as though one
species prepared the way for the
next.
One happened along in one
place, and another happened
along in another place,
and they all ended up making
communities of a fairly similar
nature.
In particular,
the hardwoods came in,
in a lot of different
sequences.
Some are going fast,
some are going slow.
So it looks like the tree
species you see in an eastern
hardwood forest can be assembled
in an almost random order.
By the way, the rates of their
dispersal are determined a lot
by what kind of seeds they had.
Something like a hickory or an
oak is going to move north about
at the rate at which squirrels
bury seeds.
So it's going to be about 50 or
100 meters per generation,
max.
Something like a maple,
that has a nice little
helicopter seed,
can go north on the winds and
can move hundreds of miles at a
clip.
So the take-home message from
Margaret Davis's analysis of the
eastern hardwood forest is
species assemblages come
together in a potentially fairly
random sequence.
It isn't as though one thing
prepares the way for the next.
Now let's take a look at what's
going on with spiders that are
ecomorphs in Hawaii.
And by the way,
these are the happy-face
spiders;
so some of them have a little
mark on them that makes them
look like they're happy.
And what are marked here are a
group of the green ecomorph,
which is waikamoi;
this one.
And then there is a maroon
ecomorph, which is this group up
here.
And we have a small brown one
and a large brown one.
So this one doesn't look too
brown, but they're called the
small brown and the large brown
one.
So you can already see that
there's something going on with
these spiders that looks
something like the lizards in
the Caribbean,
the anole lizards that have
different ecomorphs in the same
community,
and that that pattern repeats
itself on different islands.
Okay?
Now the oldest island is Kauai;
the second oldest is Oahu--of
the major islands--
and then Maui Nui--which is
Maui-Molokai-Lanai--
and which, by the way,
was all one island during the
Pleistocene--
is a younger island.
And then some of these things
are on the Big Island,
which is--the oldest rock on
the Big Island is only about
400,000 years old.
Kauai is about 5 million.
Oahu is about 2.6 million.
Oahu is 1 million something.
Yeah, 2.6 million for one
volcano on Oahu and 3.7 for the
other.
Kauai out at about 5 million,
and Hawaii at about 0.4.
So there are a couple of
messages, when you look at these
patterns.
And you should think of the
spiders as having started from
Kauai and then moved down the
chain.
And there are two things that
can go on.
You can either have speciation
or you can have assembly.
The difference in those words
means the following:
If you have assembly,
it means that a bunch of
evolution went on and generated
a bunch of species,
which we have over here in a
pool, and then they migrated;
and then communities got put
together, with pre-existing
species.
If you have speciation going
on, it meant that an ancestor
came in and that it speciated
locally,
on whatever island,
and that a community got
assembled out of the clade that
developed,
with the different species in
it.
So that's the distinction
between assembly and speciation.
Okay?
And with T.
quasimodo, you can see a spider
that evolved here,
and then spread down the chain,
so that this particular one
evolved on Oahu,
this brown one,
and then became part of the
assembly process in the other
islands.
It crops up all over the place.
So this is where that
particular species originated,
and then it became part of
these other communities by a
process of assembly.
The second thing you can see is
that the diversity of the
communities,
which is indicated when you
have four of them present,
appears to be highest--you
only, you get that on Maui and
you get it here,
on Oahu--it appears to be
highest in communities of
intermediate age.
On the Island of Hawaii,
which is young,
and on the Island of Kauai,
which is older,
the communities appear to be
simpler.
And I must say that this is
kind of a rescue process to get
this pattern,
because these--Hawaii is the
extinction capital of the world,
and so there are a lot of
people who are working to
document these patterns before
it's no longer possible.
One of the important things
that sort of confirms
Hutchinson's view of species
packing is that Rosie has never
found two species that share the
same ecomorph in the same place;
so that locally these things
sort out.
And the maximum number of
spiders you're going to get
locally is four.
And they're going to be in
these different ecomorphs.
They're going to be using
different parts of the habitat;
they're going to be behaving
differently;
and they're going to be colored
differently.
And if you go back and you ask
yourself, "How are they
related phylogenetically?"
you will see that,
for example,
the maroon one can have a green
ancestor or a dark brown
ancestor,
and the light brown one can
have usually a dark brown
ancestor,
but over here it had a green
ancestor.
So the phylogeny indicates that
the ecomorphs are arrived at
convergently,
and the phylogeography
indicates that both speciation
and assemblage have put them
together into communities;
and the local pattern indicates
that you're never going to get
more than four.
Well, take now that vision of
history,
that was given to us by
Margaret Davis and by Rosie
Gillespie and by others,
and let's ask ourselves,
are there some general
patterns?
That's what Bob Ricklefs,
the question Bob Ricklefs posed
himself.
Here you have an eastern
hardwood forest;
to remind us of what we're
looking at.
This is in the Appalachians.
The historical perspective says
that there's--
the historical and the spatial
perspective put together suggest
that there's no such thing as a
local community.
Every community on the planet
has been influenced by
large-scale processes in space
and time.
The regional and the historical
forces that are acting on
communities are just as
important as predation and
competition;
maybe even more so.
So if you want to understand
those processes,
you have to analyze them at a
scale that's big enough to see
them.
And therefore there is now a
discipline which is called
macroecology,
that tries to study these
things at the scale of the
planet, if possible.
At that scale you can see that
dispersal is integrating things
across regions,
and therefore it is causing the
process of assembly to take
place;
dispersal is bringing the
species in from other places.
And we can trace that process,
as you've seen with Rosie's
phylogenetic tree,
using molecular phylogenetics.
If you create a landscape in a
computer, and simulate this
process, there's an interesting
pattern that pops up.
This is from some of Michel
Loreau's work.
On the Y-axis we have species
richness, and over here we have
how much dispersal is going on;
how much are things moving
around the landscape?
And we have a couple of
different definitions.
Okay?
We have local diversity and
regional diversity.
So local diversity is going to
be how many species you can
count in a local patch,
and regional diversity would be
how much can you count in a
state?
Local diversity say for a lake
in Connecticut would be how many
species are in Lindsley Pond?
Regional diversity would be how
many fish do we find in the
State of Connecticut?
Something like that, okay?
So the local diversity first
increases and then decreases,
as dispersal increases.
Okay, so that means that the
uniqueness of each species
assembly is going to start going
up, as you increase dispersal
from 0.
And then as you start
dispersing right across the
whole landscape,
you homogenize it.
So the uniqueness of a local
community goes down.
The regional diversity stays
stable until local diversity
hits a peak,
and then the regional diversity
starts to decline,
along with the local diversity.
So as you just increase
dispersal more and more and more
and more,
you decrease the opportunities
for unique species to exist in
places where they're favored by
isolation,
and you get maximum
biodiversity at an intermediate
level of dispersal.
Well, if we now look at a real
world pattern,
rather than at a simulation
model, and we ask,
do we really see what we might
expect to see in something like
the Amazon Rainforest?
Then what we see is that a
tropical forest really isn't
completely assembled by random
dispersal, from some kind of
regional pool of species.
Some species are much more
widespread than expected.
So this is the reference on
that.
And basically what you see,
if you look across distance,
and look at the fraction of the
species that are shared between
any two points--
in Panama, which is a fairly
small country,
on this scale,
you can see that as you go out,
the fraction of species that
are shared,
say if you took it two points
that are fifty or sixty
kilometers apart,
they're only sharing about
fifteen percent of their
species.
But if you go into Ecuador and
Peru,
and you look at the fraction
that are shared,
across the huge expanse of
trees that are available in the
Amazon Basin,
you find that there are some
trees which are shared at great
distances.
They've spread across the
forest and they are right across
much of the continent.
So regional processes really
look quite different when you
take the map,
like a rubber,
and just stretch it out,
so that things can live in a
larger area.
And by the way,
there's quite a bit of history
going on here as well.
In the Amazon Basin,
during the Pleistocene,
much of the basin was actually
savanna--
up until about 12,000 years ago
it was fairly dry in South
America--
and there were refugia.
There was a refuge up near the
Andes in Peru and Ecuador.
There was a refuge in the
Atlantic Forest,
and then there was another one
that was up in the highlands of
Venezuela.
And that huge forest,
which now covers a third or a
half of South America,
has expanded out of those
refugia in the last 10,000
years.
And you can see that some of
those trees were probably able
to move fairly long distances,
fairly rapidly,
to get there and cover much of
the rainforest.
By the way, the rainforest of
the Amazon is not yet in stable
age distribution since the last
glaciation.
You should not think of it as a
stable ecosystem.
The thing comes and goes,
and it's in a process of
transition all the time.
Okay, today I've tried to give
you a bit of the intellectual
history of community ecology,
starting with an idea of
communities in some sort of
stable equilibrium,
determined by competition.
Then the idea of top-down
control, through predation and
dispersal;
predation giving top-down
control, and then dispersal and
assembly in a regional
framework.
And then the perspective of
time, that communities are
assembled through time,
and that this occurs at a
geological timescale,
with glaciers coming and going,
and at a longer time scale with
continents drifting.
I think that really the
communities are driven mostly by
the glacial cycle,
rather than by the continental
drift cycle.
And that means that when you
look at something locally,
you have to be able,
in your mind,
to integrate across these
levels when you form your
questions,
because they suggest important
alternative hypotheses that you
might want to test.
Okay, next time is Island
Biogeography and
Metapopulations.